fausse information beaucoup de rumeurs
beaucoup d'inexactitudes
mais surtout de leur rappeler
en réalité les bases et les fondamentaux
des réformes qui était notamment deux
avec un tronc commun des spécialités
mais d'expliquer concrètement comment
allait se dérouler la réforme et en quoi
cette réforme était profitable
aujourd'hui aux jeunes notamment dans la
perspective de l'enseignement supérieur
c'est quand même pas oublier que la
réforme du lycée à cet objectif-là
former les jeunes pour une réussie
d'enseignement supérieur qui aujourd'hui
ses 60 % d'échec des mots licence parce
qu'il a la foi inadmissible et
intolérable
on a eu un échange de près de trois
heures
des changes franc direct au
effectivement on a pu
éclaircir les points voilà c'était c'est
un échange qui était à la fois
nécessaire demandé et puis je pense
indispensable de ma part pour relayer en
tout cas une information juste et
objective sur cette réforme